foreign
[Music]
putting aside the fact that we stopped
making fun of Emos and eyeliner about a
decade ago this joke would make more
sense if you he was listening to My
Chemical Romance or Panic at the Disco
but he's listening to Billy Joel so I'm
not sure the joke works and butcher
should probably give Huey some space
before he has a heart attack
we'll say I lost my bottle a little bit
when I pumped you one yeah but losing
your bottle butcher would mean you've
lost your nerve or you became scared I
think you meant you lost your head or
you're just terrible at understanding
idioms and I'd honestly believe either
possibility so um
sorry adding a question mark to your
apology
easy there Huey Philly punched you once
you got your free shot back that's
officially settled according to man law
no more hitting unless you want to incur
further penalty shots maybe there's a
reason women live longer I think if
there's a way to screw this up you'll
find it Grace would be
diabolical at TV sins look
I just won me wife back me wife
those are not boys those are birds
wearing a Spuds McKenzie shirt in the
year of Our Lord 2020. L Karen
fogahara doesn't say one word in this
entire series but she still manages to
bring more Humanity to the show than
most of the folks who do damn it take a
sin off I wasn't aware compound V
granted the power to make crusty YouTube
critics emotional
also VIP areas and clubs am I just
sending them because I've never been
invited to a VIP area in a club yes yes
I am
placing your used dirty gloves to where
they're touching part of the fruit plate
you homelander you've completely ruined
milk for me thanks to you have had to
start putting orange juice in my cereal
now
that moment this
this became
the seven except that there's only six
of them currently and they've already
had the funeral for translucent they
couldn't have waited on this pitch until
after they filled that seventh spot but
um well effort would be nice
what a firecracker so much fun I hope
she doesn't secretly become a Nazi or
something
um excuse me but I do have two sisters
people who name drop the women in their
family when they're accused of being
pigs you don't with the money you
never
the money but you can still on the
money right my entire life is almost 100
modeled after in decent proposal so
after that the beach aquarium Red
Lobster Red Lobster uh
is this you uh hey is Huey leaving a
voicemail about exposing
compound V on starlight's phone which
could be used as evidence against
Starlight and Huey and get them both
killed
pressing your saliva Factory door
against someone else's saliva Factory
door without explicit consent not one
goddamn win Huey two seconds ago you
were saying this was mostly Starlight
you only got upset when Billy didn't
pick you up or try to kiss you so which
is it is this your win or star lights if
it's your win take the minor compliment
from Billy and move on if it's
Starlights win then tell Billy to call
and congratulate her but you can't have
it both ways offering someone an energy
drink when they're thirsty you might as
well pour a bag of sugar and salt down
their throat to quench their thirst I
know I should care about what's going on
here but all I keep asking myself is why
are there so many drawers in this room
who would need this
good one room
Kenji uses his powers to crush an energy
drink Cannon then uses it to cut through
metal chains and it
works
a stranger is just a friend you ain't
met yet yeah that's what I thought when
this guy left his Wendy's chicken
nuggets at the table next to me so he
could go wash his hands I figured he was
a friend I hadn't met yet so I took a
few but he wasn't very friendly when he
got back and found my face covered in
his honey mustard long story short turns
out she can go to jail for surprisingly
little post-mating Papa John's isn't
gonna help why would you use a delivery
service for a pizza chain that already
delivers hey uh hey Annie It's Me Again
leaving a second incriminating voicemail
before the girl you stalk can return the
first incriminating voicemail you left
or companies in crisis dude maybe wait
an hour before calling again things like
James Bond and everything why James Bond
the woman you're madly in love with did
some awesome spice you couldn't even
pick another woman's spy to compare her
to when a black widow why not the
baroness Evelyn Salt Lorraine Broughton
not you us seven there's still only six
of them is there a compound V formula
that can teach people how to count that
might be helpful you guys you are my
real
telling your co-workers that they're
your family dude that's like the
universal language for justifying work
conditions usually low pay and last
minute schedule changes I did not see
that coming from you
maybe you don't know me that well
maybe I don't you literally don't know
each other that well you two have been
working together for what two days and
homelander's been off playing daddy
dearest for the majority of that time
what world threatening scenario is the
Deep ever actually needed for even on
the rare chance that bad guys are at Sea
homelander can fly they didn't
need the D before he came at PR
Nightmare how did he ever make the seven
I mean the six I gotta say it's funny
and not to mention gross as the sequence
is it could have been better I mean
Sharknado gave us a former Beverly Hills
90210 star emerging from the belly of a
live shark with a chainsaw in
his hand I feel like that should at
least be the goal post we're aiming for
right the Diabolical and not to mention
insane the entire group survived this
without snapping their necks or
shattering their skulls whales aren't
filled with pillows you know what the
are you waiting for the second win
I guess it would have made less sense if
Huey had said he was waiting for his
Piano Man or his Uptown Girl but out of
all the Billy Joel songs were stuck with
your only human is the bookended
metaphor and I hate it they're
Gill is showing let's cover it up it's
disgusting that's gillest chicks right
Huey honest homelander not hear this
group of beating Hearts right behind him
we already know he has super senses so
what's blocking them here his concrete
his new weakness or is it the writers
the plan here you uncuff him he knocks
out homelander and then what you thought
the man whose sole goal is to escape but
just agree to get back into his
restraints
murder also seen does not contain Holly
Berry asking the question do you know
what happens to a toad when it's struck
by lightning
how did Homeland or not hear kamiko
sneaking away and how did Stormfront
forget about the second individual with
power she was just trying to kill 30
seconds ago I don't want anything bad to
happen to kamiko she's one of my
favorite characters but her Escape here
is nothing short of the writers needed
it to happen you snooze you lose Gramps
Gramps you're like 70 years older than
homelander I had no knowledge whatsoever
of all the plays to take from the 90s
presidential Playbook I'm not sure
televised denial was the right one
choosing not to shower off your whale
intestines before sitting down to watch
some TV
cases which he then blew at the five
dollar table at the circus circus dental
plan Lisa needs braces hey uh hey Annie
it's me again I just got out of a six
year relationship okay that should help
explain why I'm acting so weird us seven
three minutes
to the biggest battle of our
professional lives
come on
come on I am not a whale
is Yellow Bastard I hate
Illinois Nazis though it is important to
acknowledge can you watch this garbage